The end of last class,
I began to raise the question as to whether or not we should distinguish two
questions that we would normally be inclined to run together.
We've been asking ourselves,
what does it take for me to survive,
for me to continue to exist,
but it's possible.
I suggested that we really don't,
shouldn't focus on the question,
what does it take for me to survive,
but rather what is it that I care about?
What is it that matters in survival?
Because it's possible logically speaking that there could be cases in which I
survived,
but I don't have what I normally have when I survive and so I don't have what
matters.
I don't have what I wanted when I wanted to survive.
It could be that in the typical cases of survival,
I've got that extra thing,
but we can think of cases in which I would survive,
but I don't have that extra thing and so I wouldn't have everything that matters
to me.
So as as it were,
we might say it might be that mere survival or bare bones survival doesn't
really give me what matters.
What I want is survival plus something else.
And I tried to motivate this question by having you think about perhaps the
possibility that the soul view was the truth about personal identity,
but imagine a case of complete irreversible Amnesia while nonetheless it's still
your soul continuing but the soul is going to then having been scrubbed clean,
get a brand new personality,
new set of memories,
new set of desires,
new set of beliefs,
no chance of recalling your previous current personality.
And when I think about that case,
I find myself wanting to say,
all right,
I'll survive,
but so what?
I don't care.
It doesn't matter that it's me in that case because I don't just want it to be
me.
I want to have,
there'll be somebody that's me with my personality.
Similarly,
suppose we thought that the body of view was the correct view and we imagine
again,
some sort of case of complete amnesia.
And so then we get a new personality and he said,
well look that that's going to be you.
Your body,
your brain,
you're still around.
And I say,
oh,
could be true,
but so what?
It doesn't give me what I want.
When I want to survive.
What I want isn't just for it to be me.
I want it to be me with,
with,
with my personality.
So should we conclude therefore that what really matters is not just survival,
but having the same personality
with the expos.
The personality view of personal identity was correct.
Would that then give us not just personal survival,
but what matters?
I think that's close,
but no cigar.
Not quite good enough to see that.
Recall the fact that according to the personality view,
as a theory of personal identity,
the crucial point isn't that my personality stay identical.
It's not that I have to keep all exactly the very same beliefs,
desires,
memories,
because of course if we said that,
then you know I die.
As soon as they got a new belief,
I die as soon as I forgot anything at all,
like what I was doing 20 minutes ago.
No,
according to the personality theory,
what personality would personal identity requires?
Isn't item for item the same personality,
but rather the same evolving personality.
I gained new beliefs,
new desires,
new goals.
I may lose some of my previous beliefs,
lose some of my previous my memories,
but that's okay.
As long as it's a slowly evolving personality with enough overlap.
Okay.
So now let's consider the following case.
I started off,
here I am,
I've got a set of beliefs,
a set of,
you know,
I believe I'm Shelly Kagan set of memories about growing up in Chicago,
uh,
as such,
set of desires about wanting to finish my book and philosophy and so forth.
And I get older and older and older and I get some new memories and some new
desires and some new goals.
Suppose that I get very,
very,
very old.
I get a hundred years old,
200 years old,
300 years old,
somewhere around 200.
Suppose that my friends give me a nickname,
they call me Jojo.
Who knows why they call me Jojo.
And after a while somewhere and the name spreads.
And by the time I'm 250 years old,
everybody's calling me Joe.
Joe.
Nobody calls me Shelly anymore.
And by the time I'm 300350400 I forgotten anybody used to call me Jojo and I no
longer remember growing up in Chicago.
I remember things about my,
about my youth when I was a lad of a hundred but I can't go back to what it was
like in the early days.
Just like you can't go back to what it was like to be four or three.
And suppose that ours,
all this is going on.
As I'm getting older and older,
my personality is changing in a variety of other ways.
I lose my interest in philosophy and,
and take up an interest in,
I dunno,
something that completely doesn't,
organic chemistry holds no interest to me whatsoever.
I think I'm fascinated by the details of organic chemistry and,
and my values change.
Now I'm a kind,
I mean now over here I'm a kind,
compassionate,
you know,
warm individual who cares about the downtrodden but around 300 I say then Donald
Trump and who needs them.
And by the time I'm 500 I think I'm completely self absorbed and I'm sort of a
vicious,
cruel,
vile person.
Here I am,
800 years old,
900 years old,
Macusa law in the Bible lives for 969 years.
He's the oldest person,
so okay,
here I am,
969 years old.
I'm like,
Methuselah call this the Methuselah case and the crucial point about the case is
that we stipulate that at no point was there a dramatic change.
It was all gradual,
slow evolving and just the way it happens in real life.
It's just an ass.
Methuselah.
I live I very,
very,
very long time and by the end of it,
and indeed let's say somewhere around 600 or 700 I'm a completely different
person as we might put it.
I don't mean literally,
I mean in terms of my personality now member according to the personality theory
of personal identity,
what makes it neat is the fact that it's the same evolving personality and I
stipulated that it is the same evolving personality,
so that still need,
that's going to be around 600 years from now,
700 years from now.
But when I think about that case,
I say,
so what?
Who Cares?
When I think about that case,
I say,
true.
We'll just stipulate that will be me in 700 years,
but it doesn't give me what I want.
That person is so completely unlike me.
Doesn't remember being Shelly Kagan doesn't remember growing up in Chicago,
doesn't remember.
My family has completely different interests and tastes and values.
I say it's me,
but sort of so what?
It doesn't give me what I,
what I want.
It doesn't give me what matters.
When I think about what I want,
it's not just that there be somebody at the tail end of an evolving personality.
I want that person to be like me,
not just be me.
I want that person to be like me and in the Methuselah case I've stipulated ends
up not being very much like me at all,
so it doesn't give me what I want.
When I think about what I want,
I'm just going to invite you to each one of you to ask yourself,
what is it that you want?
What matters to you in survival?
When I think about what matters to me,
it's not just survival is not just survival as part of the same ongoing
personality.
It's survival with a similar personality,
not identical item for item,
but close enough to be fairly similar to me.
Give me that and I've got what matters.
Don't give me that and I don't have what matters that I'm inclined to go a
little bit further once you give me that,
give me that.
There's somebody there with my similar personality.
I think that may be all that matters.
Up to this moment I had been saying,
okay,
survival by itself isn't good enough.
You need survival plus something else and I'm now that my own case at least
there's something else is some of the extra is same,
similar personality.
It might be that I get what matters to me even if I had as long as I have
similar personality,
even if I don't have survival,
suppose I don't believe in souls,
but suppose the really our souls and suppose the soul is the key to personal
identity and suppose the thing that Loc was worried about really does happen
every day at midnight.
God destroys the old soul and replaces it with a new soul that has the very same
personality as the one before midnight.
Similar personality,
same beliefs,
desires and so forth and so on.
If I were to discover that's what was happening metaphysically and the sole view
was the true theory of personal identity,
I'd say,
turns out I'm not going to survive tonight.
I'm going to die.
Who Cares?
There'll be somebody around tomorrow with my beliefs,
my desires,
my goals,
my ambitions,
my fears,
my values,
good enough.
I don't really care whether I'm going to survive.
What I care about is whether there'll be somebody that's similar to me in the
right way in terms of my personality.
So it might be that the whole question we've been focusing on,
what does it take to survive me?
It turned out to be misguided.
The real question may not be what does it take to survive,
but what matters?
And it might turn out that although normally having what matters goes hand in
hand with surviving,
logically speaking,
they can come apart and what matters or,
so it seems to me at least isn't survival per se,
but rather having the same personality since I'm inclined to think that the body
view is the correct theory of personal identity.
I want to say,
look,
somebody around tomorrow,
you know,
if overnight God replaces my body with some identical looking body and keeps the
personality the same,
that won't be me.
But all right,
it's good enough.
What matters to me isn't survival per se.
Indeed.
Isn't survival strictly at all?
It's having the same personality
still.
What does that leave us?
That leaves us with the possibility that there could be cases where you die and
you don't survive.
You know,
maybe God swooped me up upon death.
my body dies,
but he's sort of swoops up my information about my personality and recreates
somebody up in heaven with the similar personality.
Won't be me.
If it's a different soul won't be needed.
It's a different body,
but still I want to say,
well,
give me what matters.
Well,
that's a possibility,
but I don't in fact think it's going to happen.
I believe I've told you I'm a physical list.
I believe that what's going to happen is at the death of my body,
that's going to be the end.
Now,
what I've been arguing is that logically speaking,
even if you are a physical list,
that doesn't rule out the possibility of survival.
Suppose you believe in the personality theory,
your body's going to die,
but your personality could continue or it might be even as a body theorist,
I'll cease to exist,
but what matters,
we'll continue.
These are possibilities,
but for what it's worth,
I don't in fact believe they're actually what's going to happen.
Of course,
these are also theological Madison,
so I'm not trying to say anything here today to argue out of the theological
conviction that God will resurrect the body or God will transplant your
personality into some new angel body.
But if you're the,
if you believe in the personality theory,
that will be you or what have you.
I'm not,
it's not my goal here to argue for or against these theological possibilities.
Having at least taking the time to explain philosophically how we could make
sense of them,
but I do want to report that I don't believe them.
I believe that when my body dies,
that's it for me.
There won't be anything that's me afterwards.
There won't be anything that even though what I want per se isn't survival.
Not only won't I survive,
I believe after my death.
What matters to me in that situation won't continue either.
There won't be somebody with a similar personality to mind after the death of my
body.
All right,
so having spent all this time getting clear about the nature of personal
identity and getting clear about,
uh,
you know,
what,
what people are and the possibilities of survival and so forth,
having argued against the existence of souls and for a physical list view,
physicalism seems compatible with both the body of view and the personality
view.
Leave it to you to decide between them.
I myself currently favor the body view.
Let's ask,
so just what his death anyway on the physicalist view might seem as though it's
fairly straightforward.
A person after all is just a body that's functioning in the right way so as to
do these person tricks.
It's p functioning as we've put it at one time or another.
And so a person,
just a p functioning body,
whether you emphasize the body side there,
the personality side of that,
of that equation,
what exactly is it to die?
When do I,
let's,
let's turn to that question.
When do I die
and what is deck?
The,
roughly speaking the answer,
presumably I'm the physicalist view is going to be something like if you,
if I'm alive when we've got a p functioning body,
roughly speaking,
I die.
When,
when that stops happening,
when the body breaks and it stops functioning properly,
that seems more or less the right answer from the physical host point of view.
Although I was,
we'll see probably later today.
We need to refine it somewhat,
but first let's ask a slightly different question.
Which functions are crucial in defining the moment of death?
After all,
we've got the idea that here's the body,
here's a function.
He body.
Here's one in front of you.
Each one of you has got one.
You're a functioning body.
There's a variety of functions that your body's engaged in.
Some of them have to do with merely digesting food and moving the body around
and making the heartbeat and the lungs open and close and call those things the
bodily functions.
And there's also,
of course in each one of our cases,
there's these higher mental cognitive functions that I'd been calling the person
functioning.
The,
you know that there's,
that there's,
there's a B functions and there's The p functions.
Well,
roughly speaking,
I die when the functioning stops,
but,
but which functions is it the body functions or the personality functions?
So let's take a look at the normal situation.
Or here's the existence of your body.
And during most of the existence of your body,
it's functioning.
It's the body functions.
Okay?
Over here it's no longer functioning.
The carps
during some of the period when your body is functioning,
it's doing the higher cognitive stuff.
So it's personality functions.
Okay?
Yeah.
This is the very early stuff.
When your body's still developing and,
and your brain hasn't turned on yet or your brain is turned on,
but it hasn't actually become a person yet.
Right?
That's at least in the case of the fetus.
It's not self conscious.
It's not rational.
It's not able to communicate.
It's not creative and so forth.
That comes later.
All right,
so there's phase a,
phase B,
phase c,
that's the normal situation.
The normal case,
the body existed functions for a while before the p functioning begins.
And then after a while,
the body and p functioning,
you're both going on and then after a while they stop.
In the normal case,
you know,
I'm in a car accident or whatever it is and my body stops functioning,
my personality stops functioning and you're left with a corpse.
When did I die?
Well,
the natural suggestion is to say,
I died here,
dropped my little star or an asterisk.
Okay,
and the normal case,
I die when my body stops functioning in terms of the body functions and it stops
functioning in terms of the personality functions.
That's the normal case though.
We can still ask the philosophical question since what we had here was
simultaneously losing,
losing both the ordinary body functioning and the special personality
functioning,
which loss was the crucial one in terms of defining the moment of my death.
Okay.
Let's come back to that question in a minute.
First,
I want to ask a slightly different question.
When did I ceased to exist
or to put it slightly differently?
Do I exist during phase c when the body has stopped functioning,
both in terms of body functions and personality functions?
I'm just a corpse.
Do I exist now?
Let's suppose we believe the personality theory of personal identity according
to the personality theory of personal identity.
For something to be me,
it's got to have the very same personality,
the same evolving,
but still the same set of beliefs,
desires,
goals,
so forth.
Now during periods,
see there's nothing with my personality,
all right?
Nobody thinks they're Shelly Kagan.
Nobody has my memories,
beliefs,
exact desires,
goals,
and so forth pretty clearly.
Then on the personality theory,
I don't exist at phase.
See,
that's why it's natural to point to the moment of star.
When we say that's when my death occurs.
I don't exist at phase c,
but interestingly,
things look rather different if we accept not the personality theory,
but instead the body theory after all,
according to the body theory of personal identity,
for somebody to be me,
they got to have my body follow the body.
Same body,
same person.
All right,
Harry are,
here's my corpse.
What is a corpse?
It's a body and indeed my corpse is my body.
Okay,
so follow the body means follow the person.
Carps is still around means my body's still around means I'm still around.
It's like,
I mean I'm dead,
but I still exist.
It's like a bad joke.
Right?
So you know,
we'll,
here's the question we started in the class off with,
you know,
will you survive your death?
Will you still exist after death?
Well,
there's good news and there's bad news since I believe in the body theory.
The good news is you will exist after your death.
The bad news is you'll be a corpse.
Right?
Seems like a bad joke.
But if the body theory is right,
it's not a joke at all.
It's literally speaking the truth.
I will exist.
Yeah.
At least for a while and then eventually the body will decay,
turn into atoms or whatever it is
decomposed.
At that point,
my body no longer exists.
I will no longer exist,
but at least for a while during periods,
see the body theorist should say,
yeah,
you will exist.
You will exist,
but you won't be alive.
Yeah.
Just reinforces the point that I was trying to make a few moments ago that the
crucial question is not survival per se.
The crucial question is what did you want out of survival?
And one of the things I wanted out of survival was to be alive.
All right,
so on the body view,
I exist here but I'm not alive so it doesn't give me what matters and the
personality view.
I don't exist when I'm a corpse.
Let's go back and ask the question.
Well,
so which is it?
Which is the one that's the crucial for defining the moment of death,
right?
Even on the body view,
the fact that I exist isn't good enough because I'm not alive.
I want to know what am I alive,
what am I dead?
So what's crucial for defining the moment of death is a body functioning or
personality functioning.
Well,
you can't tell by thinking about the normal case because the be functioning and
the p functioning
stop at the same time.
But suppose we draw the abnormal case.
All right here,
see what the corpse again,
here's a period when the body has been functioning and it goes like this.
Here's the period back here.
A way the body has been functioning,
but the personality hasn't started yet and now imagine,
so this is personality
over here we got body,
so we'll call this B again.
What I've done is imagine a case in which the personality functioning stops
before the rest of the body functioning stops.
Obviously the phases are no longer in alphabetical order,
but I introduced d in the middle,
so as the other phases could keep the,
the other phases could keep their same labels.
Well,
here's a case where when does the body functioning stop and the d,
when does the personality functioning?
Stop,
end of B.
So we got two candidates,
star one and star too.
Star one says death occurs when personality stops functioning.
Star two says says,
no,
no.
Death occurs when bodily functioning stops.
Yeah,
well then the question is what should we say?
And I think we've got to perhaps be drawn to different answers depending on
whether we accept the body view or the personality view.
Suppose we accept the body view.
Well,
look,
if the relevant question is when do I die and I am a body,
then presumably the straight forward answer,
at least it's going to be I die when my body stops functioning.
When is that
star too?
During Period d?
Yeah,
I'm still alive,
but I'm no longer functioning as a person.
I am no longer a person.
That's interesting.
It's not just that I exist in,
see,
I can exist without being a corpse or we want the right without being alive as a
corpse in d,
I'm alive,
but I'm not a person.
Okay.
You'll recall when we talked about Plato,
we introduced the notion of essential properties and it seems that if we accept
the body view,
we have to say being a person is not an essential property of being something
like me.
It's not one of my essential properties that I'm a person.
I am in fact a person.
Okay,
but that won't always be true of me.
When I'm a corpse,
I will cease to be a person,
but I'll still exist and if we have this unusual case in which my,
my brain has a,
has a stroke,
loses its higher cognitive functioning so that the body continues to breathe,
eat,
respirate and so forth.
The heart continues to pump,
but there was no longer anything capable of thinking,
reasoning.
We say,
look,
I still exist.
Indeed I'm alive,
but I'm not a person.
Being a person is something new can go through for a period of time and cease to
be in the same way that being a child is a phase you can go through for a period
of time and then cease to be,
or being a professor is a phase you can go through and then cease to be,
you can still exist without being a professor.
I can still be alive without being a professor.
Well,
on the body of view,
we have to say the same thing about being a person.
Being a person is something that I named me.
My body can do for a while.
It wasn't doing it back here in a certainly won't be doing it and see and it
won't be doing it in d either.
Being a person is something on the body view that I am only for part of my
existence and indeed only for part of my life.
Well that's what it seems we should say.
I'm the body view.
What if instead we accept the personality theory?
Then
actually one,
one more remark about the body view.
Notice that if you accept this,
uh,
kind of what the body you should say about when death is,
you know,
my death is when I cease to be alive.
I am my body so my deck occurs at star to loss of bodily function and being a
person who is just a phase.
Notice that if we say that,
then there's something somewhat misleading about the standard philosophical
label for the problems we've been thinking about for the last couple of weeks.
We've been worrying about the nature of personal identity.
That is what is it for somebody to be me,
but notice that that label personal identity,
the problem of personal identity seems to have built into it.
The assumption that whatever it is that's me is going to be a person.
Is it the same person or not?
Now it turns out that that assumption standardly built into the usual label may
be false on the body view.
It could still be me without being a person at all.
So the problem of existence through time or persistence through time shouldn't
be called the problem of personal identity,
but just the problem of identity.
Yeah.
Footnote Tony.
Now again to the personality theory,
if we accept the personality theory of personal identity,
then for someone to be me,
they've got to have the same personality and so for something for me to exist,
my personality has to be around,
well,
that's why we set up here that in phase,
see when there's a corpse,
I don't exist.
There's nothing with my personality as a corpse.
I no longer exist.
What should we say about phase d on the personality theory?
Here,
my body is functioning,
but my personality has been destroyed.
Nothing exists with my beliefs,
memories,
desires,
fears,
values,
goals,
ambitions.
Well,
if I just am my personality,
then I don't exist in phase d because there's nothing there to be me.
Nothing with my personality according to the personality theory.
Follow the personality,
the personality ended.
It's star one.
So I don't exist at phase d and the personality theory.
Okay,
good.
I don't exist,
but what should we say?
Am I alive or not?
Well,
my body still alive.
So should we say that I'm alive after all,
my body's still functioning until star too.
During Phase D,
my body seems to still be alive.
Should we say that I'm alive?
That's rather hard to believe,
right?
Think about what it would mean to say that we'd be saying,
I'm the personality theory.
I don't exist but I'm alive.
That seems like a very unpalatable combination of views.
How can I be alive if I don't even exist?
So it seems we have to say I'm not alive during phase d.
Not only don't I exist during phase d,
I'm not either yet.
My body is alive.
That's the whole stipulation.
So it looks as though the personality theorists is going to have to introduce a
distinction between my being alive on the one hand and my body being alive on
the other.
In the normal case up at the top goes to deaths occur simultaneously.
My body stops being alive at the very same moment that I cease being alive.
But in the ad normal case,
the personality theorists needs to say or so it seems to me the two deaths come
apart.
The death of my body occurs at star to my death occurs at star one
yeah,
notice that the body theorist didn't need to draw that distinction because if I
just am my body,
then well I'm just my body.
My death occurs at the death of my body.
But still,
even the body theorist needs a different distinction.
We already learned by thinking about the corpse case that existence wasn't good
enough for the body theorist.
He wanted to be alive.
And when I think about phase D,
I want to say something more,
you know,
it's not good enough that I'm alive.
I want to be a person,
so what matters to me isn't just being alive,
but being back here during phase B,
so we're going to need something like the same distinction,
not my death versus my body's death,
but perhaps the death of the person if we could talk that way versus the death
of the body.
My death for the body view occurs with the death of my body,
but in terms of what matters,
it's the death of the person and that star one,
not star too.
Now I want to take just a couple of minutes and mentioned some other puzzles or
at least questions worth thinking about in terms of the physical list picture.
I'm only going to point to them rather than explore them,
but I've been focused on the question about the end of life.
We might ask as well,
what about the beginning?
What should we say about phase a when the body is turned on and functioning,
developing,
but the brain has not yet gotten to the stage at which it's turned on or perhaps
it hasn't yet become worth not doing person functioning.
It's not rash,
it's not reasoning.
It's not.
Communicate is not thinking.
It's not aware.
It's not conscious.
It's going to be some phase a like that.
What should we say about that phase?
Do I exist during that phase or don't I?
Well,
on the
bodies you,
I suppose we should say I do exist.
Being a person's a,
a phase we happen to have in phase a the stage of my existence before I become a
person.
Okay.
Of course,
if we take the version of the body view that what I am essentially these crucial
body part is my brain,
then we really would have to sub divide a into two parts early a in late a,
you know it very,
very early age.
The brain hasn't even developed yet.
It hasn't been constructed yet.
If I just am my brain in effect,
then early Aa,
I don't exist yet.
Not until late a when the brain gets put together that I start to exist,
there's something there.
It's my body,
but it's not me.
In early Aa seems sorta hard to believe,
but maybe that's the right thing to say.
In any event,
the fans of the personality theory shouldn't be laughing too hard cause they're
going to have to say something similar.
Remember,
if you accept the personality theory,
follow the personality.
Don't got the same personality.
I ceased to exist.
That's why we said on the personality theory as we went ahead in time,
once the p functioning stops,
I don't exist anymore.
That's what the personality theorists said,
but we can raise that same point going backwards.
When did I begin to exist on the personality theory?
Not until my continuing evolving through time personality started and that
certainly wasn't true.
Way Back at the start of a,
as the,
as the fertilized egg first begins to us split,
multiply,
sub divide and make organs.
It's a good long time to any kind of mental processing occurs at all.
Okay,
so on the personality theory,
I did not exist when that fertilized egg came into being when the,
when the egg and the sperm joint,
that's still not me on the personality theory.
Clearly these issues are relevant for thinking about the morality of abortion.
I'm not going to pursue them here,
but you can see how they'd be be relevant if we want to worry about when,
if ever is an abortion justified,
it might be worth getting clear on when do creatures like us start?
Well,
interesting question,
but having noted it,
let me put it aside.
Oh,
question.
Is it possible that a,
especially in the very early stages of a embryo or fetus,
you could say the body's functioning either because,
um,
it's completely dependent on the mother's body for its survival and it can use
it.
You can do anything on its own.
All its filing functions are just affects it.
The question was,
would it be plausible to say that at the early phases of a,
strictly speaking,
the body's not functioning because it's so utterly dependent on help from the
mother's body?
It needs,
you know,
the mothers for respiration,
for nutrients,
so forth and so on.
That's a great question and it's the sort of question that is the reason why I
said I wanted to glance in this direction without really going there.
That that's a nice example of it.
We might wonder just when should we say the body functioning really does start,
how much independence does it take?
No,
we could draw yet another picture of a different way.
Life could come to an end.
Imagine a body towards the end of life on life support machinery.
Do we want to say the body's functioning and not functioning well?
Hard cases.
They're so similar.
Lou's going to be hard cases about the very,
very early stages and all the other great questions and I'm happy to discuss
them with you further.
I don't want to pursue them here and now want a point to a different question
that yeah,
I think it's a crucially important question.
My,
my,
my unwillingness to discuss them isn't a matter of my judgment that are
unimportant.
Just trying to keep at least roughly on track.
Come back to the end of life.
Think some more about phase d and ask,
all right,
so this is something that if,
if the,
if the personality function has been destroyed,
can't be recovered,
can't be fixed,
but the rest of the bodily function,
he's still going on the heart.
Breathe in,
the heart's pumping,
the lungs are breathing and so forth.
Body is able to digest food.
There we are in phase d in something like perhaps persistent vegetative state.
Okay?
Now imagine that we've got somebody who needs a heart transplant or kidney
transplant,
liver transplant and tissue compatibility tests reveal this body's compatible,
suitable donor.
Can we take it or not?
Well,
you might have,
fuck,
we answered it by asking,
am I still alive?
You know,
rip out the heart.
It's going to kill me,
right?
So if I'm still alive,
you can't do that sort of thing.
It's killing me.
Well,
if we take the personality theory,
we have to say,
my body's still alive,
but I'm not still alive.
That's what we seem to,
we want it to say,
if I'm not still alive,
all we'd be killing isn't me but my body.
So now we have to ask who or what has the right to life?
Do I have the right to life or does my body have the right to life?
Or we might say,
look,
certainly I have a right to life.
But is it also true that in addition to me,
my body has a right to life?
Is there something immoral about removing the organs during phase g when the
person is dead and the only thing that's still alive is the body,
don't be too quick to assume the answer and that's got to be yet still wrong.
After all on the body view,
I still exist when I'm a corpse,
but of course there's nothing wrong about taking my heart even though I still
exist.
After all,
I'm a corpse.
Why not then say similarly,
even though my body is still alive,
nothing wrong about removing the heart.
If the person is dead,
at least the personality view opens the door to saying that.
Okay,
what about the body view and the body view?
Of course I just am my body.
I'm still alive now is it wrong?
We're
just like with the body view we wanted to say,
you know,
being alive is not all it's cracked up to be.
The real question is not am I alive on the body of view?
They are.
An interesting question is,
am I still a person
and indeed,
although I'm alive on the body view,
I'm not still a person.
Maybe it's not so much that they have a right not to be killed.
Maybe I have a right not to be deep personified to have my personality
destroyed.
If that's the real right,
then again there'd be nothing wrong with removing the heart in d.
Well again,
clearly very,
very important and very,
very complicated questions but having gesture toward them,
I want to put them aside
stead.
I want to
raise the following question,
so look what I've just been talking about for the last half hour or so is the
fact that we've got to get clear in thinking about the nature of death as to
whether or not the crucial moment is the moment when the personality functioning
stops or the moment when the bodily functioning stops.
As we saw by thinking about the abnormal case,
these things can come apart and we can have phase d,
but in the normal case that happened at the same moment,
and I've drawn a lot of different distinctions about,
you know,
what would you say if you're a personality theorists to deal with this,
what would you say if your body has to deal with this,
having drawn all those distinctions,
I'm going to just ride rough shot over them and put them aside and let's just
suppose that we're dealing with the normal case where the body functioning stops
at the same time as the personality functioning stomps.
So what is death?
What's the moment of death?
What is it to die on the physicalist view?
Well,
at first glance you might think the answer is,
look you,
you exist,
you're alive.
Whatever it is.
You know,
as I said,
I'm going to sort of just be loose.
Now I'm going to put aside all other,
the careful distinctions.
I just drew,
I'm still around.
As long as my body is p functioning
and when my body's not functioning,
I'm not still around.
Either I don't exist or I'm not alive or I'm not a person.
Whichever precise where we have to put it.
Okay.
That seems like the natural proposal for the physical list to make to be dead is
to no longer be p functioning,
but that can't quite be right because imagine don't just imagine just to
remember what happened to you last night around 3:28 AM let's just suppose it
had 3:20 AM you were asleep and indeed you weren't dreaming.
You weren't thinking,
you weren't reasoning,
you weren't communicating.
You want remembering,
you weren't making plans,
you weren't being creative,
you were not engaged in p functioning.
If we take the simple straight forward view and say you're dead when you're not
p functioning anymore,
then you were dead on and off and on and off last night.
Oh,
I clearly doesn't seem to be the right thing to say,
so we're going to have to revise the,
the,
the p functioning or the,
the end of p functioning theory of death.
We're going to have to revise that theory.
We're going to have to refine it to deal with the obvious fact that you're not
dead all the times when you're unconscious and not dreaming,
but
refining it and just the right way.
He's going to turn out to be a surprisingly,
not straight forward matter,
or at least that's how it seems to me and right.
That's the question we'll turn to next time.